earlier today the da of Fulton County
Georgia charged former Atlanta police
officer Garrett Roth with felony murder
and ten other charges in the death of
Rashard Brooks now prosecutors also
charged a second police officer who was
at the scene with aggravated assault and
two counts of violation of oath by an
officer Rolfe who is white shot and
killed Brooks a black man last Friday
the shooting occurred after Brooks
failed a sobriety test as he was being
handcuffed handcuffed Brooks overpowered
the two police officers stole a Taser
ran away and then pointed back at Rolfe
with it and then he opened fire now
despite Brooks his actions being caught
on a body cam this is how the DA's
recounted the behavior mr. Brooks on the
night of this incident was calm he was
cordial and really displayed a
cooperative nature we concluded and
considered it as one of our important
considerations that mr. Brooks never
presented himself as a threat joining me
now in an exclusive is Lance LaRussa
former officer Garrett Rolf's attorney
Lance were you surprised to hear the DA
say mr. Brooks never presented himself
as a threat it was just a cordial
conversation it was shocking to hear
that because it's not true well the
altercation was obvious to anyone who
saw the video I mean it went on for 20
minutes the conversation about you want
to come with us do you want to and and
that went on for some time but then it's
clear that he struggled against both
officers and overpowered them so why do
you think the DA is emphasizing only the
nice conversation part which the
officers demonstrated their
professionalism I thought I have no idea
why he's doing that there's a lot of
things I have no idea why he's saying
that the one of the officers is
cooperating with the DA's office and
need that lawyers that the lawyer for
that officer says that's not true and
what they should be focused on is why it
changed from a cordial conversation to a
violent assault on two law enforcement
officers at the
moment that mr. Brooks knew he was going
to jail
Lance here's what the DEA said about
Brooks going after your client with a
Taser so he admits that there was a
Taser shot at your client although it
went above his head he said now we're
gonna get to that a moment I want to
show you how he described the use of a
Taser just two weeks ago as many of you
all know under Georgia law a Taser is
considered as a deadly weapon under
Georgia law
okay so Lance okay educate me
is it taser no longer a deadly weapon if
it misses the head of a police officer
well if it went over his head is because
it was aimed at his face and that's the
exact problem with a person who is not
trained and why it becomes a deadly
incapacitating weapon especially in the
hands of somebody who has already
committed a robbery and forcibly
disarmed one uniformed law enforcement
officer when a law enforcement officer
uses a Taser in the course of a lawful
arrest
it is non-lethal force because the
officers are trained how to shoot it
where to shoot it and one of the things
that they say is non-lethal less lethal
or taser taser taser that's done for two
reasons so the officers around them know
the officer is not shooting a weapon and
that the suspects not shooting back at
them because a Taser when it goes off
sounds like a firearm
well here's how the lawyer for the
Brooks family described the deadly
encounter with your client watch what we
were looking at is was it reasonable
proportionate and necessary you can see
the officer reached for the gun before
mr. Brooks turns around with the Taser I
mean that's clearly visible in the video
so he was already going in that
direction
going to the lethal force direction
before that taser was pointed in his
direction Lance doesn't matter they had
his hand on his gun no I think at that
point the officers should be wondering
what's going on behind him is this
somebody who has another type of weapon
that they didn't see if he's is he
trying to carjack somebody anybody in
the area is in danger and the problem is
and we saw this in the video the DEA
broke this down and said look here we
enhance the video they're 12 feet apart
look here you know officer Rolf was
leaning against a car well he's leaned
against a car because afraid he's going
to get killed and the officers
mind-brain and an ability to see does
not have the ability to enhance video
he's seeing all of this happening very
quickly he's reacting what's happened
quickly and I'm kind of getting tired of
people saying that mr. Brooks was
running away mr. Brooks was not running
away mr. Brooks turned and offered
extreme violence towards a uniformed law
enforcement officer if he was able to
deploy the Taser it would incapacitate
Officer Rolfe
through his body armor and at that point
if he decided to disarm another officer
he would be in possession of a firearm
the DA gave another view saying that
immediately for two minutes I guess in
12 seconds after the shooting he said
this happened there was no medical
attention applied to mr. Brooks when we
examine the videotape and in our
discussions with witnesses what we
discovered is during the 2 minutes and
12 seconds that officer wall actually
kicked mr. Brooks while he laid on the
ground I want to play this moment that
was also caught on body cam and get your
response
now we just saw that there there was CPR
administers administered but the DA says
it took two minutes and 12 seconds to
happen tonight can you tell us is the DA
stating that correctly my client never
kicked mr. Brooks if there was a video
of my client kicking mr. Brooks you
would have seen it he shows a still and
that one leg is planted and the other
ones bent you could be leaning down to
try to give him first aid it could have
been when he was trying to evaluate
whether it needed handcuffs and this
officer gave him CPR monitored his pulse
prior to that talk to him to try to keep
him breathing and called for EMS and
coordinated other efforts on the scene
you know and the other thing the DA said
was that he's never seen another officer
agreed to testify against a bad officer
my client testified against an Atlanta
police officer in the grand jury when
that officer had done something wrong so
this is an officer who's known to the
law-enforcement community he's known to
the DA's office and he was actually
cleared of another use of force and he
testified on behalf of the DA to
prosecute a bad officer it's a question
of whether he's going to be able to get
a fair trial in this climate certainly
in the Atlanta area it's I know you have
a lot of defense motions you'll be
filing lance and we just appreciate your
coming on and give us giving us a
different perspective thank you so much
thank you for having me